yes and now we are discussing about
agricultural videos in that tutorial we
are discussing about grain farming
process
what is the process of grain growing
these steps include planting growing
harvesting threshing and restoring the
final product by breaking down each step
of the process you will gain a better
understanding of how to produce
a high quality product with minimal
waste and the next point is what are the
steps in processing grains primary
processing involves several different
processes designed to clean sort and
remove
inedible fractions from the grains
primary processing of cereals includes
cleaning grading heel hurling Milling
pounding grinding
tempering
proper par boiling soaking drying and
sieving and the next point is what are
the seven steps of agriculture
the seven steps involved
in agriculture
in agricultural stamina steps involved
in agriculture practices are mentioned
below probing sowing adding nutrients
irrigation producting protecting plants
harvesting and Storage
our next point is what are the five
stages of grain
Oaks decimal growth scale is based on 10
cereal growth stages
these are germination number one is
germination seeding growth seedling
growth then a Tailoring
then stem elongation under booting
next year emergence
then flowering then milk development
then the dove development under ripening
these are the five stages of a grain
next point is what are the six stages of
grain farming
let us learn about how to form grains in
six simple steps understand the forms
production goals
survey the Farmland prepare the Farm
soil finally the Farm soil Harvest and
thresh the grains
store the grains our next point is what
are the methods of green harvesting with
cereals the crop is first cut either as
a whole are partially
and then the threshed and clean to
separate the grain from the years and
strong
in the latter case two main Alternatives
exist
separate harvesting and threshing
our combined harvesting and refreshing
and the next point is what are the seven
steps of grains there are many different
types of grains but some of the most
common types of grains
are wheat
barley Woods
and
rice and common types of grains to eat
is wheat
rice barley oats quinoa that is q u i n
o a kuna and Rai means Rye
and next point is what tools do green
farmers use
while a truck is often stamped of a
farming life there are several other
Farms specific
vehicles too
attract us to say that a tractor is a
broad category is an understand
underestimate understand understatement
a broad category is an understatement
combine or Harvester ATV or UTV close
Harrows fertilizer system spreaders
Cedars under balance
next point is what are 10 examples of
grains
the examples of all whole grains and
whole grain foods include barley
bulgar
Furrow Millet
that is q-u-i-n-o-a
black rice brown rice and then red rice
next point is what are the steps of
farming agricultural and
Agriculture and agricultural practices
soil preparation before raising a crop
the soil is
the soil in which it is to be grown is
prepared by a plowing leveling and
manuring sowing selection of seeds of
good quality crop strains is the primary
stage of sowing manure irrigation
weeding harvesting storage
what are the farming methods
permaculture biodynamic
farming hydroponic phonics and anapon
aquaponics Urban agriculture
agroforestry and food forests
in the farming methods Hydroponics and
aquaponics
is very good subject and science
next point is what is the life of
farming cultivation processing packaging
Transportation consumption disposal
what are the most common green topics
green types next point is what are the
most common grain types rice corn and
wheat are the most common stable food on
yet
grains are so important because they are
a good source of important nutrients
called carbohydrates
carbohydrates are a type of sugar that
provides energy for organisms to
function the next point is what are the
three common methods of preparing grains
the three most basic techniques for
cooking grains are boiling absorption
and steaming lend the best ways to
prepare and cook different grain times
including some different cooking
techniques
including frying stir frying still
frying and banking
next point is which machine is used to
cut grain crops
a machine used for cutting
the mature crop is Harvester
what is the next point is what is the
best method of farming
taking on agroforestry practices this is
one of the best farming techniques using
natural resources
mixing in trees
within your farming operations
these trees provide shade and shelter
for plants and animals in addition they
provide extra income by allowing you to
sell food or Lumber
next point is what is the traditional
method of processing the grain
traditional Crossing is usually referred
to as primary or secondary
milling and grinding the grain are
considered
primary processing processes for example
while baking the grain into Brent in
secondary processing
the less acceptable form of a processed
food is the result of territory
tertiary processing this is the
information regarding grain farming and
processing
brain forming process it is most
important and it will be this video will
be useful to so much
the methods of Performing processes Etc
by agricultural risks wishing you all
the best